we now come to questions of the chance
of the ex-checker we start with Mr John
Barron
number one Mr Speaker Chancellor
[Applause]
Mr Speaker he will know that the growth
plan my own friend will know the growth
plan really uh was a very very strong
package for business for small uh medium
sized Enterprises and I'm sure that many
of his constituents will appreciate the
strong measures that we introduced
excellent I was being slightly
Mr Speaker I refer members to my entries
in the in the register of interest in
welcoming the government's growth agenda
and notwithstanding the lack of
reassurance to the market will the
charts are seriously considering to
consider lowering taxation on smaller
businesses despite the package that's
already been announced because they are
the engine room of the economy they do
employ most people in the private sector
and if cost savings are necessary hs2
and the streamlining of a myriad of
quangos could be the first option
to tell my honorable friend that we're
going to introduce the medium-term
fiscal plan in three weeks but consider
the message the measures we've already
introduced national uh Insurance hikes
have been reversed corporation tax rise
has been scrapped and the annual
investment allowance remains at a
million pounds these are investment
these are measures which small
businesses up and down the land have
been very very appreciative
thank you Mr Speaker as my right and
wrong little friend will be aware small
businesses are the backbone of our local
economy and none no more than Caitlin
Bakery in cramlington and they have
expanded from the bakery to run the cafe
and now a dessert bar so would my right
honorable friend who's assured me that
he would this government will do all we
can to help these businesses thrive
absolutely right and of course in
relation to the bakery that he uh
mentions uh Captain Bakery we've also
supported them through an energy package
60 billion pounds for households and
businesses for six months and that's
something that we absolutely uh felt
necessary to do
not McCartney thank you speaker it's
like I never went away and I refer
members and colleagues to my entry in
the register of Interest supportive
businesses will always be a key pillar
for growing our economy and by
association our small and medium-sized
businesses which there are many of in
Lincoln and more across our County of
Lincolnshire they should be at the
Forefront of the government's growth
agenda devolved areas such as t-side in
the West Midlands have continually been
successful in delivering for their areas
greater linguishers stand ready right
now for a maximum Devolution deal
therefore will the treasury support any
such deal for greater Lincolnshire yeah
sure friend uh Knows Mr Speaker that
demolition is the heart of the
government's plans to level up and
strengthen communities and of course in
the leveling up white paper the
government has fully committed to
offering a Devolution deal to every area
that wants one by 23rd yeah Sherman
can I declare an interest to the uh
Chancellor I've actually worked in a
smaller medium business I've actually
unlike many people on these benches
worked in manufacturing industry and the
manufacturing smes in my constituency
are absolutely up against it in terms of
the cost of energy what is he going to
do to relieve them right now
I think the honorable gentleman makes a
very good uh point and represents his
constituency ably in respect of small
businesses we have introduced a package
an energy price guarantee not only for
households but for businesses which is
to the tune of 30 billion pounds uh in
the first uh six months this was
something that was absolutely necessary
and I'm very proud of the fact that we
acted very swiftly to protect uh
businesses like those in its
constituencies Sarah Owen very much Mr
Speaker the government failed mini
budget sent interest rates soaring which
is already causing mortgage pain for
Millions But Rising borrowing costs are
now threatening our high streets too
small businesses in Richmond Park and
across the UK are seeing their loan
repayments spiral and their financing
options dry up we've already seen the
highest company insolvency since the
financial crisis more than 5 600
businesses have closed in the second
quarter of this year and SME debt is now
at a staggering 204 billion most of
these businesses won't see a penny from
the cut to corporation tax what is the
charge
a number of times already the energy
package the energy support package will
help every single one of the businesses
in her constituency and I'd be very uh
pleased to see the lib Dem growth plan
the anti-growth Coalition carbs from the
sidelines but it has nothing to say
about growth Chris Brown
yeah the one thing that businesses
always want is security and
understanding of what's going to happen
for them next year they're worrying
about mortgage their borrowing costs for
next year the chancellor has already
made that more difficult for them he
says that he's got a package for
um energy costs for that does only lasts
for six months
um a Leisure company I spoke to the man
who owns a Leisure company that I was
speaking to you yesterday said that his
bill next year will be going from 100
000 pounds to 475 000 pounds he will be
closing why doesn't he bring in a proper
measure that's going to last more than
six months so I think the honorable
gentleman makes a fair point in respect
to energy costs and that is precisely
why we intervened in the way that we uh
that my right normal friend the Prime
Minister now is only a couple of weeks
ago the package is 60 billion for
households and businesses across the
next six months and that is a generous
package and we are at listening
I said Peace spokesperson now listen
foodless yeah yeah thank you Mr Speaker
businesses of all sizes are struggling
with brexit import cost material costs
the week pound against the dollar in the
Euro increased wage and energy costs and
they still don't know what will happen
when the Chancellor's temporary reprieve
ends in March the clock is ticking
Calder Miller Field a food manufacturing
business in my constituency have come
back to me with their latest quote with
relief applied 944
000 pounds per year up from 160 000 last
year what was the chancellor going to do
to support manufacturing businesses no
because they will not survive with these
increases Chancellor as I've stated the
energy price guarantee does help uh in
in a large measure of businesses and
also I'm not Mr Speaker going to take
lectures from the SMP about growing I
mean in Scotland for every year from
2010 to 2019 the growth was lower than
for the rest of the United Kingdom I'm
not going to take any uh lessons about
building Business from The Honorable
labor Lawrence Robertson
three Mr Speaker
Minister Mr Speaker the chancellor
speaks regularly to the governor of the
bank of England on a wide range of
matters as my honorable friend knows the
bank of England sets monetary policy
including interest rates independently
of government
Boris Robertson you thank the minister
for that response obviously the world
situation is the biggest cause of the
rise and interest rates but that is
having a detrimental effect on mortgage
payers of course and it risks
negativizing the very welcome help that
the government has provided through
energy costs and tax cuts can the
chancellor and the ministers meet more
regularly with the bank of England to
coordinate policy a little more closely
I thank my honorable friend for his
question he's a passionate advocate in
this place for his constituents uh the
chancellor and myself meet regularly uh
with the bank of England and with all of
the individual lending banks in the UK
my honorable friend knows that interest
rates have increased in every major
economy despite what the opposition may
claim to say and that's why it's so
important that we're providing help with
energy and cutting taxes
and thank you very much Mr Speaker but
surely ministers must now first of all
apologize for the chaos
mini budget with its 45 billion of
unfunded spending commitments in tax
cuts has caused to the bond markets and
isn't it now a fact that there is a Tory
premium on every interest rise for every
Borough in this country and they're not
going to forget it when the election
comes
Mr Speaker I think we understand it's a
very clear divide in this house between
our side which is supporting growth
which is providing which is providing
support for energy bills giving the
economy the confidence and certainty
that needs this winter and bringing
forward supply side measures that's
going to boost the economy not help not
be on the side of striking workers
bringing this economy to a halt Shadow
Minister
thank you with your permission Mr
Speaker I'd like to send my condolences
to the families of all those killed in
the tragic accident in creslo County
identical last week my parents came from
quite nearby it's a beautiful place with
a close community and a very much in our
prayers right now I'd also like to
welcome the minister to his position I'm
sure that he and the Chancellor's team
wanted our first budget to be remembered
perhaps even studied in years to come
well Mr Speaker they've certainly
achieved that ambition
two-year fixed mortgage rates are above
six percent for the first time since
2008 and they've risen sharply since the
Chancellor's mini budget everyone coming
off such a rate will face much higher
payments over the coming year possibly
hundreds of pounds a month more why
should people who've worked hard to buy
their own home pay the price for the
government's mistakes
Mr Speaker I'd like to add my comments
and thoughts to uh the incident in
County down last week
um we talked Mr Speaker already about
our comprehensive energy support package
that that helps not just every household
this winter preventing them from the
uncertainty of an NG bills that were
potentially forecast to reach six and a
half thousand pound per home but also
businesses and this is the government
that is on the support side of
businesses that's Keen to improve the
supply side of our economy so that we
can grow to create the tax revenues for
our high quality Public Services
they give us the speaker this morning
the bank of England made a further
intervention in the market warning of
and I quote a material risk to UK
Financial stability this risk comes
directly from the Chancellor's mini
budget two and a half weeks ago how much
more will government borrowing costs
next year as a result of the rising
guilt yields since the Chancellor's
statement on September 23rd
Mr Speaker as I've already observed
we're seeing interest rates rise in
every major Western economy perhaps the
opposition from benches when they're
finished with the British exceptionalism
will actually lift their eyes and notice
that what's more important is that we
are protecting consumers and households
through the difficult winter months
ahead we're cutting taxes measures that
this side of the house supports and that
side of the house opposes SNP spokes
personality thank you very much Mr
Speaker the IMF observe today that the
Chancellor's unfunded tax cuts have
complicated the Fate against inflation
as a result the bank of England is
expected to increase the base rate to
levels not seen since 2008. families
have already struggled with increasing
Energy prices and cantar say that
grocery inflation stands at 13.9 percent
Santander are preparing for increased
mortgage defaults so can I ask the
minister what are he and his tragedy
team doing to tackle the career this
absolute chaos they have created
themselves
Mr Speaker I understand that it's
absolutely inimicable to the Nationalist
party to talk this country down at every
opportunity
the reality is that we are taking the
action that we need we are tackling
supply side we are tackling the strikes
that are grinding down the economy and
we are building the energy that we need
that will help strengthen our economy
and strengthen our currency her party
oppose nuclear and they oppose more oil
and gas exploration
sir
four
Municipal yeah yeah Mr Speaker with
permission I'd like to group this with
question number 11. a critical part of
the government's growth plan is uh Road
Rail and energy infrastructure and we
will be introducing legislation very
shortly to make sure the delivery of
that critical introduction is massively
sped up yeah
yeah thank you I'm grateful for the
investment in physical infrastructure
but the uh the treasury front Branch
will know that infrastructure needs
skills we need the skills for the future
to deliver the jobs for the future to
make the infrastructure investment
sustainable so will the minister meet
with me to discuss the idea for mku a
brand new University in Milton Keynes
every single Minister and secretary of
state that I've spoken to about this
thinks it's a good idea will he meet
with me and get it off paper and get
boots on the ground Minister when I
thank my honorable friend the member for
Milton Keynes North who is a tireless
Champion for the great uh Play Store The
Great town of Milton Keynes I would be I
would be delighted uh to meet with him
to discuss this idea along with
colleagues perhaps from the Department
for education I note of course that
Milton Keynes has already received 23
million pounds in the towns fund and but
I'm very happy to meet with him to
discuss this idea
John Stevenson yeah thank you Mr Speaker
growing the economy is about improving
people's lives but also improving the
success of places like Carlisle to
achieve this we need investment both
public and private and the case of
public investment it is an
infrastructure that will make the real
difference given the rise in the cost of
such infrastructure projects can the
chancellor or the minister confirm that
where these projects have a shortfall in
funding but are ready to go that the
government will step in and give
additional funding Mr well it is very
much Our intention to speed up projects
where they are ready to go the growth
plan announced a few weeks ago made very
clear our commitment to doing that the
last spending review provided I think
about a hundred billion pounds of
funding towards critical economic uh
infrastructure but where we can speed
projects up we will certainly be doing
that and I think one of the projects
that we have in mind uh to do exactly
that for is the a66 north trans penine
route which I believe goes not far from
The Honorable gentleman's constituency
next month
Mr Speaker in 2017 former conservative
energy Minister Charles Hendry conducted
a review Into The Swansea Bay Title
Lagoon he gave it the thumbs up but
since then successive governments
haven't pursued it now given the energy
crisis we're in will the minister
consider reopening the business case it
could be a fantastic source of green
energy for our country
well the government is extremely
interested in all forms of new energy
generation we're determined to make sure
that the United Kingdom is electricity
independent there are all kinds of
projects we're looking at including of
course Marine projects I understand that
when the Swansea scheme was previously
investigated there were questions about
value uh for money but I'm sure any
proposition that is put forward wants to
do it uh we'd be very happy to take a
careful look at it
when it comes to the delivery of project
you can't help but admire the speed at
which the government has managed to
transform down the street from a
nightclub into a casino but I have one I
have one ask that isn't a gamble the
acorn project in the northeast of
Scotland when are they going to deliver
it yeah
well my everyone the chancellor says
that that is something we are examining
uh very carefully uh but let me say his
characterization of the uh growth plan I
think is extremely unfair the real risk
I would say that the real risk is in not
having a growth plan the real risk is in
having taxes that are too high the real
risk is not investing in infrastructure
what is clear is that this government
has a growth plan the opposition has no
plan
thank you Mr Speaker and of course it's
always right to look for efficiencies
and try and get better value money for
the taxpayer
as we look for spending cuts could my
right one friend confirm that those
spending cuts will not come at the
expense and reductions of vital
infrastructure spending our regions not
least in the north of England Minister
yeah well again pleased to say as the
chancellor said when he introduced the
growth plan that Expediting critical
infrastructure is an important part of
that plan uh without critical
infrastructure we're not going to see
the growth in jobs the growth in wages
and the prosperity that we all want to
see and this government will do
everything it can to speed up the
delivery of those projects so I bet you
would speak it we don't know much yet
about the government's new investment
zones but in order to achieve the
success of the Prime investment in them
will the government house specifically
targeted uh funds for infrastructure
projects in those zones and if so will
this be a further unfunded expenditure
commitment
well the um I think the chances are set
out the investment Zone concept very
clearly there would be by agreement with
local authorities planning freedoms and
also very significant uh tax cuts
infrastructure Investments are being
handled separately to that but I think
it would be reasonable to expect a
degree of coordination uh between the
between D luck and the Department of
Transport as they consider the way that
investment zones interact with transport
projects well I should have called over
Mr Speaker Minister Mr Speaker reforming
the eu's director Von bonus cap is not
about paying people more all it ever did
was increase base pay regardless of
performance it was never a cap on total
remuneration and no one should pretend
that it was
thank you Mr Speaker that was total
nonsense but our son families and
vasties struggle to keep up with the
rising cost of living this government
has chosen to help Bankers by removing
the scripts from their bonuses whilst
maintaining the cap on household Social
Security Now despite soaring bills and
growing inflation the cap has remained
stagnant since 2016 plunging hundreds of
thousands of families into deep poverty
the cap on Social Security is cruel and
how can the chancellor seriously justify
removing the cap on Bankers bonuses but
not on the social security cap so we're
here have a word with this Connie
exactly work and pensions apartment and
change that
Mr Speaker The Honorable ladies fully
booked her place as a member of the
anti-growth Coalition and in 1907 in
this government is not afraid to be on
the side of the people that create the
wealth that funds our public services in
1979 the top one percent of earners paid
about 10 of income tax they now pay 29.1
that's three times as much
a friend agree with me that scrapping
the cap on Bankers bonuses will not only
increase competitiveness but also
increase tax receipts as well Mr Speaker
yes
thank you Mr Speaker at a time when my
constituents are struggling to make ends
meet they're struggling to put food on
the table and struggling to put the
heating on this government has decided
the way to increase growth in the
economy is to lift the cap on Bankers
bonuses as Shadow City Minister not a
single person that I spoke to in the
city or a single bank that I spoke to
said this was the right policy to drive
growth in the economy so couldn't asked
a minister does he really think this
policy will drive growth in the economy
or are we going to see yet another
U-turn from his government
I can assure The Honorable lady that
this government is going to grow the
economy and it's going to grow the
economy by releasing by releasing the
burden the Yoke of Taxation whether
that's on ordinary people cutting the
basic rate of tax from 20 pence to 19
Pence whether it's today by reversing
the increase in National Assurance all
by cutting the taxes on the businesses
that she's been meeting and I welcome
that by reversing the increasing
corporation tax next
Mr Speaker
this government will back first-time
buyers by increasing the level at which
they start paying stamp Duty young
couple can now pay uh purchase the
property for up to 425 000 without
paying tax Mr Speaker it's a core tenant
of our belief to help everyone onto the
housing ladder so can I ask the minister
what assessment has he made since the
growth plan about helping people and
areas build houses for those who need it
and want it Minister my number friend
the Secretary of State for Department of
Housing local government will be making
a statement to this house in the coming
weeks Lauren said she'll love me thank
you Mr Speaker Michael Citra wrote to me
said what wild do the Tories live in I
guess one where you protect the rich and
wealthy the suggestion that the treasury
thinks that a person on 30k year can buy
home in London it's frankly laughable
and salt in a wound can I please ask
some Minister how it expects my
constituents in Vauxhall who are already
struggling to pay their rent to save on
a salary of 30k to buy a new home yeah
I'll be very happy to uh to write to
honorable lady to to talk to her
constituents about the unprecedented
intervention that we have made to
protect her constituents this winter
from their energy bills putting valuable
certainty and confidence not just into
every household but into every business
in the economy which is why today the
IMF have increased their growth forecast
for the United Kingdom
number seven Mr Speaker
uh thank you Mr Speaker in relation to
his question he will have seen that I
brought forward the publication of the
medium-term fiscal plan for the 31st of
October
Mr Speaker I think the house will agree
with me that the uncertainty over the
state hasn't exactly helped forward
planning when it came to benefits any
real cutting benefits will mean
people not have enough money to buy food
and buy clothing for their children
so does the child still agree with me
that increasing benefits in line with
inflation is the only fair Way Forward
indeed it would be immoral to do
otherwise
and as the chief executive Inverness
citizens advice bureaus point out to me
such benefit money is spent locally
within the local economy and is a boost
to what the chancellor has talked about
many times which is growing the economy
well I'm delighted to see that um our
one member of the anti-growth Coalition
is focusing uh on growth but in relation
to his specific question he will
understand that the medium-term fiscal
plan uh is coming out on the 31st of
October and I'm not going to prejudge
any measures in it Robert
thank you Mr Speaker this is my rather
than degree that's um a very important
part of the plan for growth is the
leveling leveling up fund and has my
right animal when
seen Harlow councils leveling up fun bid
which I wholeheartedly support which
would transform a derelict area of Our
Town Center into a thriving cultural
courts with jobs investment and tackling
and social behavior with these abandoned
buildings for far too long blighted the
heart of our town
I know that my right honorable friend is
a redoubtable and uh highly persuasive
uh representative of his constituents
and I'd be very happy to talk to him
about what we can do together uh to help
his great constituency
Mr Speaker the bank of England has had
to intervene not once not twice but
three times now and the impact on
Pension funds is obviously very very
significant many of my constituents are
going to be deeply worried what
assessment has the chancellor made of
the impacts on potential additional uh
pressures on the economy in the future
on public sector pension pay because of
the damage to Pension funds for
pensioners up and down this country is
that another reason why he didn't want
to publish the obr at the time of his
many budgets so the obr will be uh fully
scoring and giving a forecast ahead of
the medium-term fiscal plan in relation
to the bank of England I speak to the
governor very frequently and uh he is
someone who is absolutely independent
and is is actually managing uh what is a
global situation very effectively
[Music]
chair of this Lake commissioner Bell's
Drive Mr Speaker and Mr Speaker I very
much welcome
my right honorable friends decision to
bring forward the medium term plan and
the obr forecast he has listened and he
is right but could I caution him that
when it comes to the measures that he
puts forward to underpin that forecast
that he reaches out as much as he can of
course this side of the house and the
other side of the house to be absolutely
certain that he can get those measures
through this house any failure to do so
will unsettle the markets my right old
friend uh is absolutely right he does a
brilliant job at chairing his committee
and is full of wise counsel and he's
absolutely right that we will and should
uh canvas opinion uh widely ahead of the
publication of the plan
Alison McGovern Mr Speaker the the obr
was the creation of a conservative
government designed to curtail uh
wishful thinking in Economic Policy so
does the chancellor agree with me that
it's unfortunate to say the least that
we seem to have cabinet ministers
briefing against the economic expertise
of that independent institution
as far as I'm concerned and I speak to
investors regularly about this
the obr the obr
the obr
the obr
aham
the obr is a an institution that
commands wide respect not only in the UK
but across the world and its
independence to me is absolutely
sacrosanct yeah
price guarantee is a outstanding part of
the growth plan in King but far too few
businesses and households know about it
can I urge the chancellor to have a
nationwide mail out campaign coupled to
government taking the lead on the
reduction of energy in all public
buildings as the Germans and other
countries are doing so this has the twin
benefit of saving consumers and also
reducing taxpayer subsidies I think my
honorable friend makes an excellent
suggestion obviously I'm very careful
not to make unfunded uh spending
commitments on the floor of the house
but his suggestion is a very well made
one which we should look into
foreign
Mr Speaker the Chancellor's refusal to
publish obr forecast just over two weeks
ago played a key role in Falling
confidence in the pound Rising borrowing
costs and Market Panic his woeful
decision to avoid scrutiny by gagging
the obr helped increase mortgage costs
of working people who are now paying the
price for conservative failure the
Chancellor's Behavior has been described
by the former bank of England's Governor
Mark Carney as undercutting Economic
Institutions and Jonathan Haskell a
member of the monetary policy committee
made clear that a sidelined obr
generates more uncertainty does the
chancellor accept they are right
as I've repeatedly said in this session
the obr will have a fully forecasted and
scored response to the medium-term
fiscal plan in less than three weeks
George Freeman question eight Mr Speaker
minister
thank you Mr Speaker at the
[Applause]
at the thank you at the 2021 spending
review the government announced an
increase in public expenditure on R D to
20 billion per year by
2024-25 including funding for
Association to EU programs George
Freeman the chance to land his team for
making the treasury a growth department
and would they agree with me that
innovation-led growth is particularly
important if we want to drive up
productivity competitiveness enabled
investment that our high growth sectors
like space agritech and fusion have a
big role to play and would the minister
specifically reassure those in the r d
community that he won't be tempted to
reduce the allocation for horizon or for
science and research in the CSR in order
to reassure the markets
Mr Speaker very few members of this
house can look back on a track record of
commitment to research and development
as significant as my honorable friend
both as a minister and his back bench
and so I am happy to confirm to him that
we will abide by the spending review
2021 decision that includes funding for
core innovate UK programs for
Association of horizon Europe and for
Aria
[Music]
is he aware of what the Nobel Laureate
sir Andre geese said that top academics
are leaving the country in despair
because the government are negotiating
on Horizon Europe when will the
government do something now yeah when
they start well The Honorable lady is
right of the importance of this issue
and the United Kingdom absolutely wishes
to move forward and we would hope the EU
would move forward a place with us to
reach an agreement
I can explain
question number nine Mr Speaker minister
thank you Mr Speaker the loan charge was
announced at budget 2016 as part of a
package of measures to tackle disguised
remuneration tax avoidance our spring
statement 2022 this package was
estimated to bring an overall exchecker
yield of 3.4 billion pounds the changes
resulting from the 2019 independent
review of the loan charge have reduced
the exchequer yield by an estimated 620
million pounds
thank you Mr Speaker too many Everyday
People
the facing huge bills Untold distress
and in some cases personal harm and
indeed suicide because of a low charge
Scandal can the minister now commit can
the government commit to finally
commission a truly independent review to
deal with this minister
well I think all members of this house
who have met constituents who have been
affected by the loan charge cannot fail
to have been moved by the emotional and
psychological impact that has had on
many of them and as minister is Right
therefore that I should look at this
issue carefully and I can say to
remember that I will engage with all
interested parties on this matter
done Jarvis thank you Mr Speaker number
12.
minister
yeah
thank you Mr Speaker and it's a pleasure
to answer my first question at the
dispatch box from the member from
Barnsley Central who replied to my
maiden speech
[Music]
ER I actually like to answer this
question alongside number 17. the
leveling up white paper set out a clear
plan to level up every corner of the UK
by 2030. we're also driving growth and
unlocking housing across the UK with our
new investment zones and we're
continuing to invest billions in
Regional infrastructure including 1.7
billion allocated under the leveling up
fund of which 500 million went to the
north Elvis thank you very much Mr
Speaker it's a pleasure to see the
minister at the dispatch box and I
congratulate her on her appointment
previous chancellors have not delivered
the level of transformative resource
required to level up now I know that the
chancellor does understand the huge
potential that exists right across north
of England but for many of us the
leveling up agenda is sipping in The
Last Chance Saloon so can the minister
say what's going to be done differently
under this new Chancellor
we're absolutely committed to the
leveling up agenda and if we look at
South Yorkshire South Yorkshire received
570 million pounds through the regional
cities transport scheme 95 million
through the leveling up fund and 46
million through the shared Prosperity
farmed our Ambitions with leveling up
continue
Judith Cummins thank you Mr Speaker
Minister building on the back of
Bradford city of culturewayne and in
this momentous year for rugby league I
am supporting the plan for the
transformation and regeneration of the
home of the Bradford Bulls the iconic
utsal Stadium to become a world-class
sports music and culture Arena this plan
would be an incubator for the Ambitions
of the entire Bradford District
delivering over a billion pounds worth
of social economic benefits however
following the bank of England's repeated
interventions can the minister confirm
the leveling up fund round two will
still be going ahead in full and one
will the minister and the chancellor
demonstrate this by meeting with me
Bradford Council and the Bradford Bulls
and the rfl to discuss our Catalyst for
growth well I can absolutely confirm
that we will be going ahead with the
second round of the leveling up fund and
there should be Decisions by the end of
the year uh I wish her well in her bid
uh clearly there is an independent
assessment going on of the bids at the
moment but if it is possible to meet
them we will do that but clearly we need
to decide if that is appropriate and I
would also like to congratulate her on
her success in the first round of the
leveling up bid where she got 20 million
for squalene Leisure Center Martin
because thank you Mr Speaker the
renewable energy sector is vital to my
uh clear thoughts constituency in the
neighboring area and has done a great
deal to level up the local economy can
the minister give an assurance that
that's the support for the sector will
continue
um we are very much so committed to the
sector and I would be delighted to sit
down with the honorable gentleman to
discuss further yeah
Mr Speaker a key part of leveling up is
the creation of investment zones the
chancellor will be aware of the
proposals for a gigafactory at Coventry
airport to support UK Automotive
manufacturing does the minister agree
with me that the joint application by
labor Coventry city council and
conservative workshire County Council
for an investment Zone at uh at Coventry
airport should be uh should be
encouraged for this stuff
we're encouraging all higher local
authorities to look at the investment
zones and to apply I think that they are
a great tool for development so
absolutely I would encourage that
application great wish up
speaker I'm never so much chaos has ever
been inflicted on so many by so few will
be the motto that will prevent the
verbally down the eons for this moment
but can I ask her do they actually still
believe in this fairy tale of leveling
up isn't it now just a matter of how far
the route to level us all down minister
everything that we are doing is being
driven by a growth agenda so that we can
oh thank you Mr Speaker I'm sorry I
couldn't I couldn't hear at that moment
in time uh Mr Speaker the Eden Project
North is as far as I'm aware the only
project in the leveling up round two
that has got planning permission and
land allocated
um what I would like to know is when the
decisions will be made so that we can
get this shoveling scheme going because
even themselves have got 50 million
pounds from the table and we're asking
for 50 million pounds as match funding
in effect
decisions on the second phase of the
leveling up round will be made by the
end of the year and I wish him very well
David Linden Dr
thank you Mr Speaker I have regular
discussions with my runnable friend the
Secretary of State for work and pensions
if his question relates to the operating
budget of DWP we expect departments to
live within their existing CSR 21
allocations if this question relates to
the level of benefits uh more generally
there is a statutory process which of
course is undertaken every year no
decisions have yet been made and they
will be made into your course in the
normal way David London okay much Mr
sweetheart can I thank the minister for
his answer if not his recent tweets and
can also ask them as well if he's had
any representations from the safety
estate for whacking pensions to increase
Social Security payments in line with
inflation far too often this government
talks about its agenda for growth but
failure to increase in line with
inflation will result just in growth and
food banks in Easter house fuel poverty
in turmoil and child poverty and
billison so when's it going to do the
right thing intimate to Rising Social
Security in line with inflation
yeah well I'm obviously not going to
offer any kind of running commentary on
internal uh discussions which are going
on I said that the normal ordinary
statutory process is ongoing but of
course the government is mindful of the
uh cost of living pressures that people
um are facing I would try uh drawing of
members attention to the very large
increase in the national minimum wage I
think about seven percent that took
place last uh April or May and of course
there are also now more vacancies in the
economy than there are people on
unemployment benefits as well
confirmed to this house that the
government will not balance the
forthcoming tax cuts on the back of the
poorest people in our country
this government is first of all to make
sure that the economy is growing that
will help lift wages it'll create new
jobs and it will create a sustainable
tax base for our public services and but
as we make these decisions that my
honorable friend refers to of course
we're going to balance considerations of
fairness the cost of living pressures
that people suffer along of course with
interest of the taxpayers who are
working hard to pay tax as well show the
PAC de Mayfield thank you Mr Speaker Mr
Speaker the minister has talked about
vacancies and
season there are vacant
vacant won't benefit from the tax cut
rely on Universal Credit to make up the
Gap can't afford to work because of the
cost high costs of child care and they
are literally on the poverty line
already what is his advice to them and
will he will he give us some comfort
that the DWP will be making or the
government will make the right decision
on that rating benefits well I've
already explained that the normal
statutory process is underway but when
it comes to helping people on low
incomes I've mentioned already the very
significant increase in the minimum wage
uh just a few months ago we've made an
unprecedented intervention this year
amounting to 37 billion pounds which is
disparate already which is
disproportionately directed towards
people on Lower incomes to the one-third
of households on Lower incomes are
receiving an extra 1200 pounds this year
the honorable lady also The Honorable
lady also referred to the fact that
people earning now twelve thousand five
hundred and seventy pounds or less pay
no not a penny of National Insurance and
not a penny of income tax and that is
thanks to the action of this
conservative government
number 14.
uh the government thank you Mr Speaker
the government is encouraging business
Innovation through many ways let me
enumerate four for my colleague a
significant uplift in r d expenditures I
mentioned to manual friend the member
for Mid Norfolk uh Innovation loans of
150 million pounds over the spending
period research and development tax
release long-term investment for
technology and science which is a
competition providing up to 500 million
in government support and the British
Business Bank which is supporting
Innovative businesses including through
the future fund well thank you Mr
Speaker at owners and entrepreneurs
behind small businesses like the team
behind code ninjas in Bridge Street in
my constituency our key part of the
government's growth agenda so may I ask
little friend what steps he has in mind
that will enable smaller medium-sized
Enterprises like this to further create
jobs and growth for this uh right and
also I got the name quite correct Mr
Speaker whether it's cold ninjas ninjas
all right well maybe I can visit my own
friends constituency to learn about what
they do but what I would say more
generally what I'd say more generally is
the growth plan did focus on important
measures to support small businesses
that wish to grow including making the 1
million AIA allowance permanent looking
to expand the amount of money that can
be given to small businesses to grow
through the seis fund and of course most
importantly through the government's
energy price support through this winter
we don't come to topical Stephanie
peacock typical question number one Mr
speaker thank you Mr Speaker
this government is Relentless
relentlessly focused Mr Speaker on
growing the economy Putin's barbaric war
in Ukraine continues to put pressure on
gas prices so it was absolutely right
that with predictions of typical bills
reaching four to six thousand five
hundred pounds a year Mr Speaker people
needed immediate support to get them
through this winter last month we set
out the growth plan which will focus on
breaking out of the high tax low growth
cycle that we were currently trapped in
this will put more money in people's
pockets and raise living standards for
all our people Mr Speaker this week I
wrote to my right honorable friend the
member for Central Devon to inform him
that I will set out the medium-term
fiscal plan on the 31st of October to
remind the house and I wish to remind
the house that this will be accompanied
by a full economic and fiscal forecast
published by the office for Budget
responsibility
thank you thank you Mr Speaker the
chancellor sat in a cabinet that
committed to increasing Social Security
payments in line with inflation why were
any honor that promise
as John said repeatedly in my uh
honorable my normal friend has uh we
will be uh no decisions have been made
there's a a natural usual uh statutory
process that's being undertaken and we
will have uh more detail at the time the
medium term Fiscal pack it's a putter Mr
Speaker the chancellor will know that
Essex is a pro-growth county
um and a half of economic growth so in
order to support job creation and more
economic growth will he commit to
funding the dueling off the a120 between
Braintree and Mark's Tay and importantly
along the route that the County Council
businesses of the local community have
specified
um I wish to address her and pay tribute
to uh her role in cabinet in government
she's a fantastic colleague
and I wish to confirm that the a120
Braintree to a12 remains under active
consideration alongside the rest of the
Third Road Investments Factory pipeline
we could up to shut the chancellor
relationships
thank you Mr Speaker since the
Chancellor's disastrous mini budget just
18 days ago we've seen wild swings in
the value of the pound guilt yields up
100 basis points in a single day and the
bank of England stepping in because in
their words of a material risk to UK
Financial stability and the IMF has now
said that UK growth is to slow further
next year this is a British crisis made
in Downing Street no other government is
sabotaging their own country's economic
credibility as this government is so Mr
Speaker can I ask are the chancellor and
the Prime Minister the last people left
on Earth who actually think that their
plan is working
just to pick up on a point the IMF said
today that actually the plan the mini
budget has increased uh the the forecast
for growth exactly that's exactly that
so it's precisely the opposite of what
the honorable lady has said and it's
very clear where we stand on this we've
got pro-growth pro-enterprise
pro-business conservatives on one side
and the anti-growth Coalition on the
other side who want to tax more and want
to commit us to low growth Rachel Reeves
Mr Speaker the chancellor is in a
dangerous state of denial but the costs
of these mistakes are all too real for
everyone else borrowing costs up growth
down mortgage payments set to increase
by 500 pounds a month now they Scrabble
around looking for cuts hitting the most
vulnerable and hitting our Public
Services it does not need to be this way
so will the chancellor now put aside his
pride do the right thing for our country
end this trickle-down nonsense and
reverse the budgets
[Applause]
so which of the tax
are they committed to having a high tax
uh economy and the other thing I would
suggest is that she should get her facts
right the IMF today have said that our
growth is going up not going down
Mr Speaker early results from my local
business survey strongly suggests that a
lower vat rate would increase investment
which herself then would boost recovery
and growth in the hospitality sector in
my beautiful constituency of Eastbourne
uh will my right honorable friend be
reviewing the case for a lower rate to
bring us back into line with some of our
International competitors
but they stop uh thank you thank you Mr
Speaker Eastbourne is indeed beautiful
as indeed is Northeast bedfordshire and
many other parts of the of the country
and my honorable friend is absolutely
right to talk about the importance of
vat to the hospitality industry
particularly as we move through the
period of covered recovery but as we now
move towards the growth plan we need to
look at the level of taxes on small
businesses in general and that is a key
part of the uh work that I'll be looking
at as part of the tax simplification
plan goes to Nelson thank you Mr Speaker
push payment fraud losses increased by
71 in the first half of 2021 with the
losses from that type of fraud so
surpassing card fraud for the first time
so what steps is the chancellor taking
to tackle this huge surge in this road
and importantly to ensuring that victims
including my constituents are reimbursed
for their losses instead of being
unfairly penalized for falling victim to
these increasingly sophisticated scams
minister
Mr Speaker push payment fraud is indeed
a growing problem it's one the
government takes very seriously it's why
we'll be taking powers in the financial
services and markets bill that will
mandate reimbursement to Consumers
it's a it's a massive relief that the
nightmare scenario of energy bills of
four or five or even six thousand pounds
has been prevented by the energy price
cap will the government explain how
they're they're reducing the cost to
taxpayers of that scheme and stabilizing
the energy market for the future
absolutely I think my right honorable
friend was 100 righteous notice that the
energy intervention uh was exactly the
right thing we're going to have a
commitment uh to fiscal responsibility
which will stabilize uh the the economic
situation and picture and I'm sure that
her constituents will fully understand
what the growth plan is all about it's
about putting more money into their
pockets so we can have a growing and
dynamic economy
continue
thank you Mr Speaker good afternoon Mr
Speaker the Scottish government
announced yesterday that they will be
doubling the December bridging payment
which is granted to low-income families
to 260 pounds
the child poverty Action Group noted
deaths will make a real difference to
households struggling with the cost of
living crisis what plans does the UK
government have to follow suit and bring
in targeted measure for low-income
households yeah Chancellor so is my
right humble friend the chief secretary
said earlier
most of the measures that constitute 37
billion pounds intervention were
targeted directly at vulnerable uh
constituents all our vulnerable
constituents here uh in this house the
energy price guarantee also is going to
be greatly beneficial uh to people
across our country who are suffering
from the cost of living there is a huge
amount of intervention that this
government is is committed to and of
course our top priority is to make sure
that everyone can get through uh
challenging times as best they can or a
troll thank you speaker the chancellor
has provided vital support for families
across Seven Oaks and swanley with their
energy bills but for my more rural
constituents who are off the main gas
grid they've seen heating oil prices
rise over double in the past year the
100 pound support is welcome but can the
chance that and the business secretary
review the support in light of these
severe price Rises yeah yeah absolutely
I mean frequent uh contact with my right
honorable friend the business secretary
we actually sequestered we dedicated a
pot specifically to help people who are
off the gas grid but we're very happy uh
I uh and my right honorable friend to
help uh her uh my honorable friend and
her constituents uh in this challenging
time
thank you Mr Speaker in the light that
the bank of
things having to go even further to
refinance the UK go bond market what
what Chelsea had with the pensions
regulator about the viability of defined
benefit schemes and the devaluation of
defined contribution schemes or
annuities where workers going to have to
pay for this yeah
my honorable friend of the financial
Secretary of Treasury and I are engaged
with all the Regulators particularly the
pra and we will be absolutely committed
to getting to the bottom of what's
happened in the long particularly the
long dated guilt Market where it's been
over leveled over the last few weeks
mark thank you very much uh Mr Speaker
the chancellor said that he's going to
set out a fully costed plan to get debt
falling as a proportion of GDP which is
confirmed at the dispatch box will be
done in just under three weeks time the
institute for fiscal studies in their
report this morning suggested that in
order to do so there will need to be
fiscal tightening of around 62 billion
pounds by the next in the next four
years does the chancellor agree with
their analysis and if he doesn't as I
suspect is the case can you just set out
for the house why not
as I've said absolutely I'm not going to
pre-judge what's in the medium term
fiscal plan which is good which he will
which will be fully scrutinized not only
by the obr but I'm sure by the right
honorable gentleman my friend the right
honorable uh member
um himself so I don't think it's right
for me to to prejudge or anticipate uh
the measures there uh today Christian
Jardine thank you very much uh Mr
Speaker
um currently the IMF despite the
Chancellor's confident whereas the IMF
is predicting that inflation will last
longer in this country than in other
similar economies and in my constituency
of Edinburgh West where we have half the
national average rate of unemployment
and claimants people are so concerned
that more than half of them are talking
about cutting their essential budgets
and 20 according to recent reports are
concerned that they might have to turn
to food banks for the first time so when
will the chancellor reassess the
potential impact of this growth plan and
accept it maybe he's got it wrong
very specifically said this morning that
the 2023 forecast for growth in this
country has gone up as a direct
consequence of the mini budget in in
respect of uh helping uh constituents up
and down the land we have already
committed to 37 billion pounds of energy
support this year we've committed to a
further 60 billion in respect of
households and uh businesses over the
next six months and we are committed to
making sure that every uh one of our
constituents uh gets through this winter
as best would they care sir
Mr Speaker I've had numerous residents
such as those at Harwood bar Caravan
Park get in touch about the 400 pound
energy support scheme the previous
Chancellor confirmed that there was an
equivalent scheme for those in caravan
parks and park homes can the chancellor
please provide an update for my
residence and Harmony
of heating oil there is a a pot of money
that is going to be reserved for people
to help people who are off the grid and
that's something that we've already made
announcements about but I'd be very
happy to speak with her and also with my
rad honorable friend the business
secretary
thank you Mr Speaker Chester City walls
cost about 600 000 pounds a year to uh
upkeep but that money has to come out
the local authorities highways budget
can the government set aside a small
amount of money to help local
authorities with the stewardship of
internationally important Heritage
assets
Minister government continues to support
the Heritage and cultural sector there
are several sources of funding from
government arms length bodies such as
the national orange Lottery Heritage
fund and historic England's repair
grants so I would encourage the right of
the honorable gentleman to look into
those pull herbs thank you Mr Speaker
since the 1970s residents in Italy have
long been expecting and have been
promised at times funding for the
chicken Hall Lane bypass including being
allocated funding in the 2015 red book
will the chief will the minister agree
to meet with me and Hampshire County
Council to discuss getting this sorted
for people who've waited
well my honorable friend is a tireless
advocate for this and other projects in
his constituency and of course I and
perhaps colleagues from the Department
of Transport would be delighted to meet
with him and his County Council
colleagues to discuss this important
project
thank you Mr Speaker the chancellor was
warned that unfunded tax cuts would
force the bank of England to increase
rates and that's exactly what's happened
and the bank of England today has said
that the mini budget in effect has
caused the material risk of Britain's
Financial stability can the chancellor
explain can the chancellor explain
explain how people are supposed to pay
their mortgages that have gone up by 500
pounds on average and 900 pounds in
London what is he going to do about it
because it is not acceptable that his
incompetence is risking people's
livelihoods I'm sure so two uh points to
that firstly the bank of England did not
say that the mini budget uh increased
risk that they certainly did not say
that the second issue is that of course
uh as a global rates are rising uh rates
are rising throughout the world uh there
is expression that's precisely why we
thought that uh it right and it was
absolutely right to have the energy
Intervention which was for two years I
mean the labor plan was only six months
let's not forget that and secondly to
reduce the burden on people uh by
reducing taxes the
to talk to people working in the Housing
Industry in Winchester they're not
convinced that the stamp Duty reduction
will help first-time buyers while
inflation and particularly mortgage
rates are creeping up then lenders are
coming back with some good rates in the
chancellor will know that but when he
delivers his statement on the 31st of
October will he ensure that it has
confidence at its heart and knowing him
it will be this a relentlessly positive
statement so that we can push confidence
right away through the market it will be
relentlessly uh upbeat
um there are challenging times and we've
got to live within our means and there
will be an absolute iron commitment to
fiscal responsibility duplicate thank
you Mr Speaker will the minister admit
that if the government doesn't increase
the guarantee credit component of
pension Credit in line with inflation
this year it's effectively cutting the
incomes of our poorest pensioners when
they need help most we're absolutely
committed to fairness and helping the
most vulnerable in our society we're
always committed to that and I will not
pre-judge or anticipate measures in the
medium-term fiscal plan uh this
afternoon Dr Ben Spencer thank you Mr
Speaker will my writing will frame
confirm that the cuts to National
Insurance will not only help working
households but also businesses and the
public sector such as schools
he's my honorable friend and
constituency neighbor dare I say is
absolutely right the reversal of the
planned increase in National Insurance
will help businesses will help
individuals and also will help the
institutions that he refers to
I'm a holiday thank you
for the state how much the investment
zones are worth and how they will be
funded
there will be a more detail about
investment
investment zones my radical friend the
Delux secretary of state will be
updating the house on the uh specifics
on the Investments final question Kevin
Holden right thank you Mr Speaker the UK
is quite rightly for us in around 30
billion pounds of Russian foreign
currency reserves a number of countries
are moving from freezing those assets to
seizing them to play reparations for
Ukraine would my right or my friend look
at similar measures in the UK
because I've been discussed in the past
I think my the the
um the honorable the right honorable
member for sorry Heath uh did uh talk
about this earlier in the year and these
schemes are always being looked at in
light of what is an increasingly Bleak
situation uh in in Russian Ukraine
volatile